Congratulations, I'm guessing this problem took you a bit to figure out. My
teaching assistant Congard de Kana came up with this problem so it was fun for
me to solve in my own way. The key insight for me was that each step needed to
be a constant distance up and forward from the previous step. From the second
step I started by adding the height of the first step to its location. This
first step's height is the vertical step's pieces height plus the step's
thickness. The other piece of the puzzle is how far forward the second step is
from the first. From the diagram we see that this is the horizontal step depth
minus the step thickness. With these two values in hand I could create a loop to
generate all of the steps. Here's my code. At the top I computed the height and
depth I needed to offset between each step. Through experimentation I found I
needed to make six steps with my loop. On each loop iteration I modified both
the vertical and horizontal parts of the step by adding in the height and depth
offsets.